the one thing always certainly learned
from some season sell game appearances
that Lannister's always pay their debts
but what if that leads to the downfall
of the house itself the fourth episode
of the previous season provided us some
insight into how source is handling the
lenders financial dealings with our own
Bank of brows in the depths of their
present live at the iron bank means with
Cersei for second time and congratulate
Cersei truth her family's murder she had
repaid all the Lancers debt to the bank
touch of leather Circe by pointing out
that she seems to be almost surpassing
her father in this regard well this may
sound like Queen Cersei just
accomplished a great achievement it may
actually have been the move that will
seal her fate basically in this theory
Titan was purposely not repaying his
debts to the iron bank as a strategy to
keep the financial institution
interested in the land strain if there
are still owed money but the reigning
family then of course the bank would
prefer them to stay in power so it can
make its money back the key difference
between Tywin's and Cersei strategies is
that timing knew that while the
Lannisters were in debt to the iron bank
the bank had a vested interest in their
success
now that Cersei has paid out the debts
the iron bank really has no reason to
support the Lannisters their own Bank
supports and funds a person they see
capable of being successful in the long
run but most importantly they cited the
safer investments let's take a look on a
scene from the third episode of the
previous season on a winner we don't
make that we invest in endeavors we deem
likely to be successful fancy way of
saying bad now let's take a look on a
scene that took place a few episodes
later soon the armies that win wars we
have the tyrell gold we have the iron
bank behind as we can buy mercenaries
the same as all men but they'll fight if
they're well paid which they will be I
just saw that a threat to fight they'll
be turning master on me they'll beat any
army I've ever seen killing our men
wasn't war for them it was sport
her dragon burnt a thousand wagons
Qyburn scorpion fight balls bigger than
you they couldn't stop it and she has
three of them
this is no more we can win so what do we
do
foof apiece if both Jaime and Cersei
Revere the day the Lannisters have no
chance of defeating the nearest universe
is to replace their huge losses with
mercenaries why would the iron bank
supports our silver Daenerys
well they don't touch any stories the
representative of the armed bank did the
shirt sir say that they will support the
chosen victor of the Iron Throne was
their debt is paid but that doesn't
necessarily mean they will support the
Lannisters perspective with Circe
herself as the current queen but rather
a person they consider will land on the
Iron Throne once the war is over in the
season 7 finale Cersei explains to Jaime
how she will use the iron bank support
to prevail in the end but that may not
be so easy since the bank most certainly
doesn't see Cersei capable of being
successful in the long run no capable of
winning a war against Daenerys Targaryen
and Jon Snow in conclusion the
Lannisters unpaid that was what kept the
armed bank interested in House Lannister
success for so long now that her debt is
fully repaid there's nothing obligating
the iron bank to support Circe in a war
against Daenerys and her allies if this
comes true if the Aran bank truly turns
their back on Cersei Lannister even
points out the ultimate irony that if
Cersei loses she will fall because she a
Lannister paid her debts